we're back and former Vice President Joe
Biden his new book is promised me dad a
year of hope hardship and purpose so mr.
vice president when I read this book
what's at the heart of it what's at the
center of this but the center of it is
two things one that I wanted people know
what an incredible young man my son was
and I also wanted people to who people a
lot of people have gone through what
I've gone through without any of the
help I've had and I didn't want to be
about grief alone I wanted to let them
know there that you could find you can
find hope and purpose and and I really
mean that you know
immanuel kant's phrase that there's
three things the happiness something to
do some of the love and something to
look forward to it's all about trying to
take wood bo what I think my family
thinks Bo would be doing where he's
still here and doing it and it gives you
it gives you purpose it gives you a
sense of him still you know being with
you there's not but you tell a very
beautiful story in the book mr. vice
president about the death the murder of
police officers in New York City and you
were talking to the widow of one of the
police officers and you said take a
calendar and on that day of the death
mark what told the story well when I
lost my wife and daughter when they were
killed right after got elected a
tractor-trailer hit them and people
would come up and say I know how you
feel and after a while you feel like
saying it's awful you know they mean
well you feel like saying you don't have
any idea I got a call from governor news
of New Jersey I never met he was 40
years my senior he told me he knew what
I felt he said I know what you're
thinking and he told me how his wife
died suddenly when he was going home to
lunch he should an aneurysm and so on
and he said I give you a piece of advice
he said every day they said the down
days will be just as down as the moment
you heard the news but and you'll think
I'm never gonna get better he said but
here's what I want you to do every night
you go to bed mark on the calendar from
1 to 10 what kind of day you had one the
day you heard the news 10 the day the
best day like he won't have any tents
but he said don't look at it for six
months and then put it on a graph and he
said you'll see the down days are
further and further
further apart how does that how did that
help it helps because it makes you
realize there is I am actually making
progress I am able to do something and
you'd be amazed the number of people in
this book to come to me and say you know
I do what you said I keep a calendar I
keep a count yeah mr. vice president
and then that family of the NYPD officer
who had been assassinated you gave them
your personal cell phone well sure I
mean look when you've been amend the
recipient of so much generosity and
empathy and it's so easy and it makes
you it gives you a purpose to give back
to the people and so I I went out to see
I you may remember was the middle of
that the potential riots because the
african-american men killed on the
street by the police officers and then
he was acquitted and they were acquitted
and I was asked to come when those two
police officers are assassinated and I
guess it was 25,000 cops showed up I
can't remember but a lot of cops because
I have a great relationship with the
cops and an overwhelmingly positive
relation with the african-american
community so they asked me to come and
speak but I then went out to Brooklyn to
mr. Liu's house his son had died he just
got married they lived in the house with
her parents and they didn't have the
funeral because they're waiting for the
Chinese relatives to come from the
funeral and I walked in and mr. Liu was
a Dominion of man he just hugged me and
he stayed under my arm he just kept
holding on to me and and when he walked
out in the cold with me and just and
here I was eight months later my son
died and there was eight hours of people
in line literally eight hours to come
view my son's casket and I'm standing I
look up and I see mr. Liu standing there
yeah and all he did was walk up and just
hugged me and he was giving me comfort
and he didn't really even speak English
no just old Cantonese and he but he
didn't have to speak you there are no
words at that time but you know as proud
as you are Bo he was just as proud of
you you write in the book how bo would
say to you dad be alright be alright are
you alright as you said what are you
good yeah everybody spoke to speak so
glowingly a bow your say you're sitting
down across from a kid who's old young
boy what's the one thing he needs to
know to grow up and be well I think the
one thing you need to know is you have
to you have to be just straightforward
and honest you have to it it's the
building block for everything that
happens in your life and I mean it
really truly is it's the building block
for everything and and my dad had an
expression he say everyone and he meant
it every single person entitled be
treated with dignity no matter what my
father would never walk by a shoeshine
guy or a CEO without saying I give
without it seriously and I point out you
know you were asking me Gail about the
book where we're in Nantucket Island a
secret service I'm in one car we had
people who were volunteering to be maybe
with us a guy driving this named Ethan
my son and my grandson are in the car
the Secret Service goes left they go
straight and my grandson was then five
years old says driver driver and my son
said pull over the car and he opened the
I got in the back he said hunter nobody
is addressed by what they do this is
Ethan nobody's a driver honey do you
understand me nobody that's the way we
were raised and it's amazing people
respond also each
when you when you look at this
administration and how it's being run on
a daily basis what's what's your biggest
concern my biggest concern is foreign
policy my biggest concern is two pieces
of that I think the president
understandably because it's back on is
devoid of any depth of knowledge in
foreign policy but he seems not to be a
student of the detail and then you have
a guy who's really a bright guy but he
is who's the Secretary of State but
they're decimating the State Department
can you imagine we're in a situation and
East Asia and we don't have a Secretary
of State before he said can you imagine
I mean and as a friend of mine who was
the number two guys the State Department
said you can go up in the seventh floor
and hollering hear an echo in the State
Department I mean this is the time to
engage and to have more diplomacy so the
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson made
some news yesterday he said that with a
the US should negotiate with North Korea
without preconditions yes do you think
that's right
yes I think you have to talk you have to
talk look here's the deal it's a
difficult there are two things the
president ice talked to the Trump
administration about in the interregnum
period one was health care and the other
was Korea
there was an intractable problem every
president's had not had the answer yet
but the one thing everybody knows you
have to have China Japan and South Korea
on the same page and here the president
a couple months ago he's referring in
the president of South Korea as an
appeaser taking on the it's just do you
share the view that North Korea in no
way should ever get access to any kind
of nuclear weapon or is containment as
some people have talked about a
possibility as it did well I think based
on the conduct in this administration
the next president could be left with a
policy of containment the reality is I
think the likelihood of being able to
put together this Rubik's Cube which is
difficult to do but possible is not
likely in this administration and so I
think the end results going to be
a policy of containment and and to try
to move from there the next president I
predict will inherit that circumstance
but the real worry now is their
submarine capability and whether they
get that the North Koreans whether or
not they get the capability to have a
sea launched a submarine-launched
missile and so we need to double down on
what we're doing with China and what
we're doing with the rest of the world
to even tighten the sanctions further
but I think nikki Haley has done a good
job at the UN I think that the
unfortunately the sector state
constantly gets undercut by the
president he goes off to negotiate
something somewhere nothing going to
happen here I mean what a hell of a way
to run an apartment you saw something
interesting when you said you haven't
you haven't ruled it out but you're
certainly not thinking about running for
president you said I'd like to see who's
up and coming who's going to be out
there do a lot of things there's a lot
of talented people out there and but I
think the next care to name any names
well I'm afraid I'll leave people out
but you know you just had Kristin
Gillibrand and you had the senator from
New Jersey there so there's a whole lot
of really really talented people but we
need somebody who's going to be really
up to speed and be totally confident in
the area of foreign policy and someone
who is going to be and I think there are
a number able to do this or be able to
reach out across the aisle you can't run
this democracy without consensus you
can't do it it's not possible mr.
vice-president Joe Biden thank you so
much for joining us and for this
conversation we appreciate it
thank you for talking about my book how
I know your book promise me Dad it's on
sale now it's a terrific book thank you